From PRI, Public Radio International.
来自国际公共广播电台（PRI）。
Public Radio.
公共广播。
Public--
公共——
Radio International.
广播国际。
One more time.
再来一次。
It was one of those moments that play on your sense of hope. You start to picture it, easy money. The story went like this.
那是那种会激发你内心希望的时刻之一。你开始勾勒出一幅画面：轻松赚钱。故事是这样的。
Al's granddaughter had this dream where she saw the devil. He looked it up for her in a book of lottery numbers that he got in New Orleans. The book said if you dream of the devil, play the number 171. Then he saw a pill that had rolled onto the floor. On the pill was written a number, 771.
阿尔的孙女做了个梦，梦见她看到了魔鬼。他在新奥尔良买的一本彩票梦境书中帮她查了查。书上说，如果你梦见魔鬼，就买171这个号。然后他看到一颗掉在地板上的药丸，药丸上写着一个数字，771。
And it wasn't that he really believed that he was going to win. But he thought if he doesn't play and the number comes up, he'd feel like an idiot.
并不是说他真的相信自己会中奖，但他觉得如果他不买，而这个号码真的开了，他会觉得自己像个傻瓜。
And I want 771. Give me $30 straight on it.
我想要771。给我买30美元的直选。
Al buys 30 $1-tickets and then boxes it for $2. The place he goes, Hannah's Finer Foods & Liquors, a little store on 87th Street here in Chicago in a well-kept, working-class, black neighborhood, sells more lottery tickets than any location in the city. Al plays every day.
阿尔买了30张1美元的彩票，又花了2美元买了个组合玩法。他去的那个地方叫“汉娜精致食品与酒类店”，是芝加哥87街上一家小店，位于一个维护得很好的工薪阶层黑人社区，那里的彩票销量比城里任何地方都多。阿尔每天都买。
So do you think it's possible to get something for nothing?
那么，你认为不劳而获有可能吗？
Hell, yeah. Yeah, you can get something for nothing once in a while. Very few people. Not everybody.
当然可以。没错，偶尔你可以不劳而获。极少数人。不是每个人。
How much do you think you invest in the lottery every year?
你觉得你每年在彩票上投入多少钱？
Oh, I don't know. Anywhere from $3,000 to $4,000, maybe $5,000 in a year's time.
噢，我不知道。一年下来大概三千到四千美元，也许五千。
No, $3,000 or $4,000 a year is what you're paying to the lottery?
不，三千或四千美元一年，这是你付给彩票公司的钱？
You figure it come pretty close.
算下来差不多是这样。
$3,000 or $4,000 a year. That's not something for nothing.
一年三千或四千美元。那可不是不劳而获。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
But if you hit it-- if you hit it--
但如果你中奖了——如果你中奖了——
This is the thing about something for nothing schemes. Once you get the details, once you get involved, it's not something for nothing. You pay. One way or another, you pay. And we all know that. But even though we all know that, we just want to believe.
这就是所谓“不劳而获”计划的关键所在。一旦你了解细节，一旦你卷入其中，这就不是不劳而获了。你付出了代价。不管通过什么方式，你都在付出代价。我们都知道这一点，但即使我们都知道，我们还是想相信。
A delivery guy named Leo stands in line in his delivery uniform. He spends $40 to $50 a week on the lottery. But he tells me, he believes the lottery is fixed. Fixed. The million dollar winners, he says, they're usually white people. Never blacks. He notices.
一个叫里奥的送货员穿着制服排在队伍里。他每周花40到50美元买彩票。但他告诉我，他相信彩票是内定的。内定的。他说，百万美元的赢家通常是白人，从来不是黑人。他注意到了。
They tell you what suburb it came from. And sometime they show the people on TV. And like you say, this is the largest lottery place in Chicago. If they know this is the largest lottery place in Chicago, they ought to let some of these people win here once in a  while. That's fair.
他们会告诉你彩票是从哪个郊区开出来的。有时候他们会在电视上展示中奖者。正如你所说，这是芝加哥最大的彩票销售点。如果他们知道这是芝加哥最大的销售点，他们就应该让这里的人偶尔中一次奖。那才公平。
I know, but if you really don't think you can win, why would you play at all here?
我知道，但如果你真的觉得不可能中奖，那你为什么还要买呢？
Well, you try anyway. I keep playing. Maybe, like I say, once in a while, they let somebody win here. Maybe I'll be one of 'em.
嗯，反正总得试一试。我继续买。也许，就像我说的，偶尔他们会让人在这里中奖。也许我就是其中之一。
This is just how strong our hope runs. Leo believes the lottery is fixed so black people cannot win. And he still plays every day.
这就是我们内心希望的强大程度。里奥相信彩票是内定的，黑人不可能中奖。但他还是每天都买。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, the dream of something for nothing. Act One, Hands on a Hardbody. A get-rich-quick scheme in Texas involving two dozen people, three nights without sleep, and a $15,000 Hardbody truck. Act Two, Guinea Pig Zero. A guy who makes his living by selling his body or, actually, renting his body to medical science, drug studies. Act Three, Tao of the Dumpster. How an everyday dad quit his 9-to-5 and decided to put food on the family table by diving into grocery store dumpsters for it. And how this something-for-nothing scheme affected his marriage. Act Four, somebody who actually does strike it rich and gets something for nothing, and how it drives him nuts. Stay with us here, at the only place you really can get something for nothing, listening to the radio.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是：不劳而获的梦想。第一幕，“手触硬汉”。这是一个发生在得克萨斯州的快速致富计划，涉及二十多个人，三天三夜不眠不休，争夺一辆价值1.5万美元的“硬汉”皮卡。第二幕，“小白鼠零号”。一个靠出卖身体，实际上是把身体租给医学科学和药物研究的人。第三幕，“垃圾桶里的道”。一位普通父亲辞去了朝九晚五的工作，决定通过翻找杂货店垃圾桶来维持生计。以及这个不劳而获的计划如何影响了他的婚姻。第四幕，一个真正发了横财、实现了不劳而获的人，以及这如何让他发疯。请留在这里，在唯一真正能让你不劳而获的地方，听广播。
Act One, Hands on a Hardbody. Well, every year a Nissan dealership in Longview, Texas, sponsors this contest. 24 people stand around a $15,000 Hardbody pickup truck. When the starting whistle blows, each person puts one hand on the truck. They wear white gloves so as not to mess up the paint job. And they stand there and stand there until, one by one, people get tired, they drop away. And finally, one person is left standing. That person gets to keep the truck. How tough could this be? Under the contest rules, you get a 5-minute break every hour and a 15-minute break every 6 hours. And to the contestants at first, it sounds like easy money. Something for nothing.
第一幕，“手触硬汉”。嗯，每年得克萨斯州朗维尤的一家尼桑经销商都会赞助这个比赛。24个人围着一辆价值1.5万美元的“硬汉”皮卡车站着。当开始的哨声响起，每个人都要把一只手放在车上。他们戴着白手套，以免弄脏车漆。他们就这样一直站着，直到一个人接一个人感到疲惫，离开比赛。最后，只剩下一个人站着。那个人就能把车开走。这有多难？根据比赛规则，每小时有5分钟休息时间，每6小时有15分钟休息时间。起初，参赛者觉得这听起来是轻松钱。是不劳而获。
I think it's gonna be easy. Because it's all in the mind. And I have so many friends that are going to come see me. My boyfriend's going to come see me. My dad said he would get up every night at 12:00--
我觉得会很容易。因为这全靠心态。而且我有好多朋友会来看我。我男朋友会来看我。我爸爸说他每天晚上12点都会起床——
I think I'll last because I'll look at it as payments. That's what's gonna kill you when you buy a new vehicle. When I think of getting no sleep, that's gonna be painful. But you can get rest later.
我想我会坚持下去，因为我把它看作是分期付款。买新车的时候，那才是最折磨人的。想到不睡觉会很痛苦，但休息以后总会有机会的。
So that's the first thing I'll do is sell the truck. I have so many bills to pay off. I have a car. I want to go back to school. And I want to get braces. There are just so many things I want to do that I really do need the truck. And I'm determined I'm going to win it.
所以第一件事就是卖掉这辆车。我有太多的账单要还。我有一辆车。我想回学校读书。我想戴牙套。我有太多想做的事情，所以我真的需要这辆车。我下定决心一定要赢。
These interviews are part of a movie about this contest. Filmmakers Rob Bindler, Chapin Wilson, and Kevin Morse take us through the contest hour by hour. And over the course of the documentary, we get to know several of the contestants pretty well, especially one guy, Benny Perkins.
这些采访是关于这场比赛的纪录片的一部分。电影制作人罗伯·宾德勒、查平·威尔逊和凯文·莫尔斯带我们每小时追踪一次比赛。在纪录片的过程中，我们相当深入地了解了几位参赛者，尤其是本尼·珀金斯。
Benny had actually won the contest a few years back and had returned to try and win again the year they made their film. Benny says emphatically that this is not easy money, though it all starts simply enough.
本尼其实几年前就赢过比赛，那年他们拍电影时他又回来试图再次获胜。本尼强调说，这不是轻松钱，尽管一切开始时看起来很简单。
OK, on the first day, you're ready. You're up. It's just like a normal work day. And you go through the day being extremely bored. You're listening to the radio. There's people going around, walking around, coming up. And that takes away from some of the boredom.
好吧，第一天，你准备好了。你很兴奋。这就像正常的工作日。你一天都在极度的无聊中度过。你在听收音机。有人走来走去，过来聊天。这减轻了一些无聊感。
But you're standing in one spot, and you're doing absolutely nothing. And so your mind is looking for input, anything, something. And everybody pretty well yacks around the truck. And we get to know each other.
但你就站在一个地方，什么都没做。所以你的大脑在寻找输入，任何东西，什么都行。大家都在车边闲聊。我们互相认识了。
The thing is this contest usually lasts for three days and nights. Three days and nights. Or even longer. At some point, your problem is no longer boredom.
问题是，这种比赛通常持续三天三夜。三天三夜。甚至更久。到了某个时候，你的问题就不再是无聊了。
What happens is you go slowly insane. The mind has got to rest. The body can work 24 hours a day, 7 days a week. But your mind has got to rest. You have to have sleep. And when you deprive your brain of rest, then you start going slowly crazy.
你会慢慢疯掉。大脑必须休息。身体可以每周7天、每天24小时工作，但你的大脑必须休息。你必须睡觉。当你剥夺大脑的休息时，你就会开始慢慢疯掉。
It's an awesome thing. It really is. And it's something that if you haven't experienced it, try it some time. Try staying up in one spot. You feel like you get transported from town to town, place to place. You see things that aren't there.
这是一种可怕的事情。真的是。如果你没有经历过，试一次吧。试着站在一个地方不睡觉。你会感觉自己像是在城镇之间、地点之间穿梭。你会看到根本不存在的东西。
For instance, there was one time when I thought I was at a piano bar. And the back of the cab was actually, in my mind, the back of the piano. And someone was playing it. I couldn't see them. I couldn't raise up high enough to see over it, to see who was playing. And I remember standing there, looking around, and saying, "OK, I'm in a piano bar, and somebody's playing the piano. Where's my drink? Somebody forgot to bring me a drink." And that type of thing goes and comes and goes. It comes and goes. And you get extremely sleepy. And you just get numb.
例如，有一次我以为我在钢琴酒吧。在我的脑海里，驾驶室的后部实际上是钢琴的后部。有人在弹奏。我看不见他们。我没法站得足够高去越过它看看是谁在弹。我记得站在那里，四处张望，说：“好吧，我在钢琴酒吧，有人在弹钢琴。我的酒呢？有人忘了给我上酒了。”那种感觉时有时无。它来了又走。你变得极度困倦。你只会变得麻木。
My son was there, and he and another young man were throwing a baseball. And as the baseball would arc through the air, I could see traces of it. I could see 1,000 baseballs go across the front. And I saw that, and I said, "Wow." I didn't see that. It wasn't real, but I saw it.
我儿子在那儿，他和另一个年轻人正在投棒球。当棒球在空中划出弧线时，我能看到它的轨迹。我能看到一千个棒球从前面飞过。我看到了，我说：“哇。”我并没有真正看到。那不是真的，但我看到了。
Now there at the second day, my feet hurt. They got to hurting pretty bad. And I had complained about it. I was going to drop out. Because I was really having some pain. Well, several hours passed. I hung in there. And my feet went numb. And I said, "I don't think I can stand here now." And then I got to thinking about that while I was there and running it through my mind. And I said, "Well, I don't think I like numb. I don't know what's going on." And so then I started working my feet around while I was standing and keeping the circulation moving. Because that's what it was. The blood was pooling in my legs.
到了第二天，我的脚很痛。痛得非常厉害。我抱怨过。我打算退出的。因为我真的很痛苦。好吧，几个小时过去了。我坚持住了。我的脚麻木了。我说：“我现在觉得我没法站在这儿了。”然后我在那里的时候开始思考这个问题，在脑子里琢磨它。我说：“好吧，我不喜欢麻木的感觉。我不知道发生了什么。”于是我开始在站着的时候活动脚部，保持血液循环。因为就是这样。血液在腿部淤积了。
And I got the notion that everybody's legs was swelling up. Of course, they were all standing there in shorts. I had on the tightest pair of blue jeans I could find. And I wasn't showing off. I just wanted that extra support. A fellow could wear support hose, but then everybody'd be calling you sissy or something on the truck. And you'd be wanting to punch them out. Be going with that. I did. I had on the tightest pair of jeans I could find.
我产生了一种错觉，觉得所有人的腿都肿了起来。当然，他们都穿着短裤站在那里。我穿了一条我能找到的最紧的牛仔裤。我不是在炫耀。我只是想要额外的支撑。一个人可以穿弹力袜，但那样大家就会叫你娘娘腔或者别的什么。你会想揍他们。就是这样。我穿了我能找到的最紧的牛仔裤。
I love to compete. I'm a competitor. And I'm also a little bit predatory. And to win at something like this, during the time that it's happening and afterwards, you've got to be a little mean. Because there's times when people-- when you're talking to each other's head, and you're messing with each other's head. And there's a lot of that goes on. And it's mind games is what it is. Head games. Be standing there and say, "Hey, man, my legs and feet are killing me." And somebody pipe up and say, "Well, hey, I'm not hurting anywhere." "Well, what are you taking? Cocaine?" That's what you want to say.
我热爱竞争。我是一个竞争者。而且我也有一点掠夺性。要赢得这样的比赛，在比赛进行期间和之后，你必须表现得刻薄一点。因为有时候人们会在跟你说话时干扰你的思维。这种情况发生了很多。这就是心理游戏。思想博弈。你会站在那儿说：“嘿，伙计，我的腿和脚快痛死我了。”有人会插话说：“嘿，我哪儿都不疼。”“好吧，你吃了什么？可卡因吗？”这是你想说的。
And that's what I said back to him. I said, "Well, if you're not hurting, then you're numb. And you're worse off than we are. Because when you go numb, you don't know what's going on." Well, that messed with him, I'm sure. But that's the kind of thing that goes on.
这就是我对他说的。我说：“好吧，如果你不疼，那你就是麻木了。你的情况比我们更糟。因为当你麻木时，你根本不知道发生了什么。”好吧，那肯定干扰了他的思绪。但这就是所发生的那种事情。
There was one gentleman that-- I think there was three or four of us left. And a friend of his came up to the chain and asked him what he wanted to eat on the next break. And he turned around and says, "I don't know." And he literally did not know what he wanted to eat. And I realized this. And I said, "Man," I said, "this is bad. You don't know what you want to eat." I said, "I know exactly what I want to eat, what I'm going to eat when we come off on this next break." I said, "And you're standing here, and you don't know?" I said, "That's really bad." I said, "You're losing." I said, "You may as well quit now."
有一位先生——我想当时剩下三四个人了。他的一个朋友走到警戒线边，问他下一次休息时想吃什么。他转过身说：“我不知道。”他真的不知道自己想吃什么。我意识到这一点。我说：“伙计，”我说，“这很糟糕。你连想吃什么都不知道。”我说：“我清楚地知道我想吃什么，下一次休息时我会吃什么。”我说：“而你站在那儿，却不知道？”我说：“那真的很糟糕。”我说：“你要输了。”我说：“你还是现在就退出吧。”
I said, "I know exactly what I'm gonna eat. I know exactly what I'm doing. And I know exactly what I'm saying right now." And it just blew the guy's mind. He couldn't deal with that. It was more than he could deal with. And it wasn't very long after that that he dropped off. And then when he dropped off, I turned around to Dan-- that was the guy that was with me at the end-- told him, I said, "Look," I said, "you're standing next to the devil." And I said, "And you're riding the road to hell." I said, "I'll stand here 'til you die. You may as well quit now."
我说：“我知道我到底要吃什么。我知道我到底在做什么。而且我知道我现在到底在说什么。”这简直让他崩溃了。这超出了他能承受的范围。没过多久他就退出了。当他退出后，我转过身对丹——那个最后和我在一起的家伙——说，我说：“听着，”我说，“你就站在恶魔身边。”我说，“而且你正走在通往地狱的路上。”我说，“我会站在这里直到你死掉。你还是现在就退出吧。”
The only way that I can be beaten, as far as I'm concerned, is if there was someone that had just got out of the Marine Corps. That person could possibly beat me. They would have the mindset for it. It's a contest, they say, of stamina. But it's who can maintain their sanity the longest. And that's what it is. That's what it comes to. Because when you go insane, you lose.
就我而言，我唯一能被打败的方式是如果有刚从海军陆战队出来的人。那个人可能会打败我。他们有那种心态。他们说这是耐力的竞赛。但这是看谁能维持理智最久。这就是本质。这就是问题的关键。因为当你疯掉时，你就输了。
Everybody starts feeling it the second night. And there were several that dropped off, on up until the sun came up. After the sun come up, it was a long time. The third day, it was a long time. I think there was about eight of us left, five of us left the beginning of the third day. It's really roomy. And you keep wondering, "Well, who's going to go down next?" And this is when you start getting the really big rushes. When it gets down to like five people and somebody drops off, you get this awesome exhilaration. And you feel like you could jump to the moon. It just [WHOOSH]. It comes up on you. You feel it all over. And you just get the shakes.
第二天晚上每个人都开始感到压力了。太阳升起之前有几个人退出了。太阳升起后，时间变得很漫长。第三天，时间过得非常慢。我想开始第三天时大约剩下八个人，五个。这里空间很大。你会一直想：“好吧，下一个会倒下的是谁？”这时候你开始会有那种巨大的冲动。当剩下五个人，有人退出时，你会感到一种美妙的兴奋。你感觉自己能跳到月球上。那种感觉直接涌上来。你全身都能感觉到。你会开始颤抖。
I would compare it to killing a deer the first time. The first time you kill a really big animal, it's an exhilarating thing. You get so excited. And you feel absolutely, totally human. You feel it. And at the same time, you feel really sad for this person. And you feel sad for them, you feel sad for their family. Because they've been up there all this time, and they lost. They don't get nothing. It's sad. You want to cry. But at the same time, you're pumped up.
我会把它比作第一次猎鹿。你第一次猎杀一只非常大的动物时，那是一种令人振奋的事情。你感到非常兴奋。你感到完全、彻底的人性。你能感觉到。与此同时，你又为这个人感到非常难过。你为他们感到难过，为他们的家人感到难过。因为他们在这里站了那么久，结果输了。他们什么都没得到。这很悲哀。你想哭。但与此同时，你又充满了斗志。
When it gets down to the last two, that's when it gets really tough. Because he's got most of his friends and family there. Most of your friends and family are there. And then you've got fans, people that, by this time, they've picked out who they want to win. And everybody's rooting for somebody. And if you look over here into the friends and family and fans of this other person, they're looking at you like, "OK, you need to quit." Or if you're looking better than this other person, they're really upset with you.
当剩下最后两个人的时候，那才是最艰难的时候。因为他有大部分的朋友和家人在那里。你大部分的朋友和家人也在那里。还有观众，到这时候，他们已经选好了自己支持的人。每个人都在为某个人加油。如果你看看这另一个人的朋友、家人和粉丝，他们看着你就像在说：“好了，你该退出了。”或者如果你看起来比另一个人状态好，他们真的对你很反感。
And you can see it. And it deals with you. It really works on you. And you don't like it. You say, "Hey, man, I don't deserve that." And then you get to thinking about, "Well, hey, all these people are up here. And don't they realize that we're suffering, that we're hurting?" And you feel like they're bloodthirsty in a way. They're there to see this spectacle. And it seems so absurd, very absurd at the time.
你能看出来。这会影响到你。这真的会折磨你。你不喜欢这样。你说：“嘿，伙计，我不该承受这些。”然后你会开始想：“好吧，嘿，所有这些人都在这里。难道他们没意识到我们在受苦，我们在疼痛吗？”你会觉得他们某种程度上嗜血。他们是来看这场奇观的。这在当时看起来太荒谬了，非常荒谬。
There was a gentleman that was standing to my right. And he really needed to win the truck. I would say he needed to win it more than I did. And I had told him-- during the process we had become close friends-- and I had told him, I said, "If it comes down to just you and me," I said, "I'll lift my hand up, and let you have this truck because you need it. You need it more than I do."
我右边站着一位绅士。他真的需要赢走这辆车。我会说他比我更需要它。在比赛过程中，我们成了好朋友，我告诉过他，我说：“如果最后只剩下你和我，”我说，“我会把手抬起来，让你赢这辆车，因为你需要它。你比我更需要它。”
And when he started losing it, he raised his hands up and he took his gloves off. You have to wear gloves, cotton gloves. He just threw them over there. And he's sitting there, rubbing his hands like this, looking at them. And it was this hand. I grab it, and I slap it down on the truck. And I said, "Man, what are you doing? Have you lost your mind? What's going on? You're supposed to stand here with  me 'til the end. You better stay with me." And he snapped out of it.
当他开始支撑不住时，他举起手，把手套摘了。你必须戴手套，棉手套。他把它扔到了一边。他坐在那里，像这样揉着手，看着它们。那是这只手。我抓住它，把它拍在车上。我说：“伙计，你在干什么？你疯了吗？怎么回事？你应该跟我站到最后。你最好和我在一起。”他回过神来了。
Because he was losing his mind. He saw something on his hands or felt something that he just didn't like. And his little wife and family were standing over there. And they saw what I'd done. And they thanked me. But he went off. On the next break, we all took off, sat down in our various spots. And when I came back to the truck, he didn't get back up.
因为他当时正在崩溃。他在手上看到了什么或感觉到了什么让他很不舒服的东西。他的小妻子和家人站在那边。他们看到了我做的。他们感谢我。但他还是支撑不住了。下一次休息时，我们都走开了，坐在各自的地方。当我回到车边时，他没再站起来。
You experience a great camaraderie with these people because they have been through this. They've been there. They know what it's like. And it's like the guys that come back from the space program. The Right Stuff. They've got a camaraderie that they share. It's a closeness that nobody else can really understand. Because they haven't been in space.
你与这些人有一种伟大的情谊，因为你们都经历过这些。他们也曾在那里。他们知道那是什么感觉。就像从太空计划回来的人。那种“太空先锋”。他们分享着一种情谊。这是一种别人无法真正理解的亲密感。因为他们没去过太空。
After I won this truck, my self-esteem and my self-worth went through the roof. There was times I felt that I couldn't control it. I felt as though, at times, I was extremely conceited. And I've had a little trouble dealing with that.
赢得这辆车后，我的自尊心和自我价值感爆棚了。有时候我觉得我无法控制它。我觉得有时候我极度自负。我在这方面遇到了一点麻烦。
I remember sitting in my front stoop, right in front of my door. And I'd just sit there and look at it. And I'd spend two or three hours just sitting there, looking at it in total disbelief that, wow. I really did that. I really won that truck. I really went through that. I'll drive it 'til the wheels fall off, then glue 'em back on, and drive it some more. If I have to clone a new engine in it, I will. Until it just falls apart and it won't drive no more, that's when I'll set it up. And I'm gonna set it up out at the farm. I'm not gonna haul it off to an iron yard somewhere that'll scrap it. It doesn't deserve that.
我记得坐在我家门口的台阶上，就在门口。我只是坐在那儿看着它。我会花两三个小时只是坐在那儿，看着它，完全不敢相信，哇。我真的做到了。我真的赢了那辆车。我真的经历了这一切。我会一直开到轮子掉下来，然后把它们粘回去，再开一阵。如果我必须在车里克隆一个新引擎，我会的。直到它完全散架不能再开了，我才会把它安置起来。我打算把它安放在农场里。我不会把它拖到某个废铁场去。它不配那样的下场。
Later on, I experienced some awesome cases of deja vu when I would go to sleep and dream that I was back on the truck. And  I couldn't leave. And I would say it was probably three or four months afterwards that my feet and legs recovered. At night, after I'd go to bed, my feet would tickle.
后来，我经历了一些美妙的似曾相识的瞬间，当我睡觉梦见自己回到车上时。我没法离开。我想大概四五个月后我的脚和腿才恢复。晚上上床后，我的脚还会发痒。
Benny Perkins was interviewed for the film Hands on a Hard Body, which shows many people, not just Benny, going through this ordeal. It's really something. And in the year since we first broadcast this story, the film has come out on DVD. The actual contest ended in 2005.
本尼·珀金斯为电影《手触硬汉》接受了采访，电影展示了很多人，不仅仅是本尼，经历了这场磨难。这真的很震撼。自我们首次播出这个故事以来，这部电影已经发行了DVD。比赛实际上在2005年结束了。
[MUSIC - "SIX DAYS ON THE ROAD" BY DAVE DUDLEY]
（音乐 - 戴夫·达德利的《路上的六天》）
Act Two, Guinea Pig Zero. Well, a few years ago, Bob Helms noticed how many of his friends were making money by volunteering for medical experiments. In a good medical study, they put you up for 10 days or so with 8 or 10 other guinea pigs. They feed you. They rent videos for you. You can read or write all day. Of course, they give you an experimental drug, take your blood. Typical pay for a good study like this? $200 a day. $200 a day.
第二幕，“小白鼠零号”。嗯，几年前，鲍勃·赫尔姆斯注意到他的很多朋友通过报名医学实验来赚钱。在一个好的医学研究中，他们会让你和其他八九只“小白鼠”住上十天左右。他们给你提供食物。他们为你租录像带。你可以整天阅读或写作。当然，他们会给你实验性药物，抽你的血。这种好的研究典型的报酬是多少？每天200美元。每天200美元。
Bob Helms' zine about this, it's called Guinea Pig Zero, rates various medical facilities for best food, staff attitude, best money, and all sorts of stuff like that. He says that there is basically a community of people who do this.
鲍勃·赫尔姆斯关于这个的杂志叫《小白鼠零号》，评价各种医疗设施的食物、员工态度、报酬以及各种此类事物。他说，基本上有一个做这行的人群。
You're not gonna get rich. You could do it for a living if your expenses are very low. And you can do it for a living if you have another income. Or some people will actually book them very close together, so that they're doing them more often than they're telling the doctors that they're doing them. It's a little bit disgusting to do it too many times, I think.
你不会发大财。如果你的开销很低，你可以以此为生。如果你有其他收入，你也可以以此为生。或者有些人会把这些实验安排得非常紧凑，以至于他们参加实验的频率比他们告诉医生的要高得多。我觉得做太多次有点令人作呕。
When do you cross the line into disgusting?
你什么时候会越过令人作呕的界限？
Disgusting is when you're doing something very painful and getting very little money in return. Like the spinal tap studies. They have to train people how to do spinal taps. They're actually paying you $100 to take this spinal tap. This trainee drains the fluid out of your spinal cord. And sometimes you walk away half paralyzed, it's leaking, and things like this. This is disgusting. And I just don't want to-- I never go near anything like that.
令人作呕是指你在做一些非常痛苦的事情，而得到的钱却很少。比如腰椎穿刺研究。他们必须训练人们如何做腰椎穿刺。他们实际上付你100美元来做这个腰椎穿刺。实习生把你的脊髓液抽出来。有时候你会半身不遂地走开，脊髓液在漏，诸如此类。这令人作呕。我就是不想——我从不接触那种东西。
The most painful and uncomfortable one I've ever done was actually the behavior of my stomach while a radioactively-traced egg sandwich was disintegrating. And they were taking photographs of my stomach from a gamma counter. And I had a tube down my nose into my intestine and a catheter in my arm. And I had to lay very, very, very still for about eight hours at a time. So that was a very uncomfortable deal.
我做过的最痛苦和最不舒服的一次实验，实际上是关于我的胃在放射性示踪的鸡蛋三明治分解时的行为。他们用伽马计数器给我的胃拍照。我的鼻子里插了一根管子进肠道，手臂上插了一根导管。我必须每次保持非常、非常、非常静止达八小时之久。所以那是相当难受的一次经历。
How much you get paid for that?
那次你得到了多少报酬？
$200 each time, and it was three times.
每次200美元，一共三次。
Compare yourself to other people who hire out their bodies.
把你和其他出卖身体的人比一比。
Well, I sometimes think of it in comparison to, say, an art model, a nude model who models for art classes or artists. In a limited way, it's similar. You also could be compared to a sex trade worker, either a prostitute or an erotic dancer.
嗯，我有时会拿它和，比如说，艺术模特相比，那种为艺术课或艺术家当模特的裸体模特。在有限的范围内，是相似的。你也可以拿它和性工作者比较，无论是妓女还是脱衣舞者。
Let's go through a hierarchy of different people who sell their bodies, rent their bodies.
让我们列一个出售身体、租借身体的人的层级。
Well, on the top of the heap would be a professional athlete. But of course, that takes a very intense concentration. And it's different in a lot of ways. It's different in a million ways.
嗯，位居顶端的是职业运动员。但当然，那需要非常强烈的专注。它在很多方面都不同。它在一百万个方面都不同。
So the next one down from athlete would be?
那么运动员下面的一层是？
Would be a very highly-paid fashion model. At the bottom would be probably a prostitute doing very dangerous and extremely unpleasant work for money. Guinea pig would probably be somewhere in the lower half, not in the middle or the upper half.
是薪水很高的时装模特。底端可能是为了钱而从事非常危险和极其令人不快的工作的妓女。小白鼠可能处于下半部分，不是中间或上半部分。
You're saying below fashion model but above prostitute. Above nude dancer? Below nude dancer?
你是说低于时装模特，但高于妓女。高于裸体舞者？低于裸体舞者？
Well, pay-wise, it's probably below nude dancer. It's probably well below nude dancer. But as far as the aggravation and the unpleasant interactions with people that one would need to go through, it's probably above, a Guinea pig being less stressful and less of a weird pain in the ass to do.
嗯，按报酬来说，可能低于裸体舞者。可能比裸体舞者低得多。但就一个人需要经历的折磨和令人不快的互动而言，可能更高，做小白鼠压力更小，不像那样让人心烦。
How would you compare this to, say, a job working for minimum wage, a McDonald's job, where, essentially, you're renting yourself out for a fee?
你怎么拿它和，比如说，最低工资的工作，麦当劳的工作，本质上你也是为了报酬而租借自己相比？
It's much, much, much better.
它好得多，好得太多了。
Explain how.
解释一下为什么。
A fast food restaurant job, you're committed to eight hours every day or whatever number of hours. Say, eight hours every day. So that every day has got this gigantic hole in it that you can't do anything else. And all of that time, you're working hard. And you're getting very little, very, very little in return. That's not really enough for a day. A person should get more than that for a day's work.
快餐店的工作，你每天要被困八个小时或不管多少小时。比方说，每天八个小时。所以每一天都有一个巨大的漏洞，你什么也做不了。而且在那段时间里，你工作得很辛苦。你得到的报酬却很少，非常非常少。那对于一天的工作来说真的不够。一个人一天的工作应该得到比那更多的报酬。
Do you feel this job is easy money?
你觉得这工作是轻松钱吗？
Yes. Ideally, that's all it is. It's easy money. But there's a danger in thinking about it that way too much. Because one should always understand that there is always a risk. It may be a very, very small risk. It may be a really great risk that you're taking. And I think one of the particular strong risks is in doing psychiatric drugs.
是的。理想情况下，它就是这样。它是轻松钱。但想得太多有危险。因为一个人应该始终明白，总是存在风险。风险可能非常非常小。你也可能在冒很大的风险。我认为其中一个特别大的风险是做精神药物实验。
I know from reading Guinea Pigs, you do not do studies with psychoactive drugs. You call the people who do that-- you have a word for them, a phrase for them.
我从《小白鼠》杂志上知道，你不做精神类药物研究。你管那些做实验的人叫——你有个词形容他们，一个短语。
The phrase is "Brain Sluts." It's more harsh than most guinea pigs would use. It's disgusting because they're becoming retarded for money. I'm just very sensitive about the mind. I personally don't lay it out for rent.
这个词叫“脑残妓”。这比大多数小白鼠用的词更刻薄。这很恶心，因为他们为了钱把自己变傻了。我只是对大脑非常敏感。我个人不会把大脑拿出来出租。
Is your main experience of doing this just that it's boring? Is that the main downside of the whole thing?
你做这个的主要体验就是无聊吗？这是整件事的主要缺点吗？
It can get pretty boring sometimes. If it's a very long study, you start to feel like a caged animal. It's gets very aggravating. And you start to feel like you're in a fish tank.
有时候会变得相当无聊。如果是非常漫长的研究，你会开始感觉自己像只笼中动物。这变得非常令人烦躁。你会开始觉得自己像在鱼缸里。
Well, you are.
嗯，你确实在鱼缸里。
Yep. You sure are. You're under a microscope.
没错。你确实是。你在显微镜下。
And you are.
你确实在。
Yep.
没错。
When people describe a really bad job, the thing they say is, "My boss, he's just on me all the time. He's just watching me all the time. I can't get him out of my business." And that's the premise of this job.
当人们描述一份真正糟糕的工作时，他们会说：“我的老板一直盯着我。他一直在看我。我没法摆脱他的纠缠。”这就是这份工作的前提。
Yep. That's it exactly.
没错。就是这样。
And yet, somehow, you feel a sense of freedom when you're doing it?
然而，当你做这件事时，你却感到一种自由？
Yes, when everything's going well.
是的，一切顺利的时候。
Since we first ran this story, Bob Helms has stopped publishing Guinea Pig Zero and has left the world of drug testing. He has released a collection of stories from his zine called Guinea Pig Zero: An Anthology of the Journal for Human Research Subjects.
自我们首次播出这个故事以来，鲍勃·赫尔姆斯已经停止出版《小白鼠零号》，并离开了药物测试的世界。他发行了一本从他的杂志中选出的故事集，名为《小白鼠零号：人类研究对象杂志选集》。
[MUSIC - "RUN ANOTHER TEST ON ME" BY KAIA]
（音乐 - 卡亚的《再测我一次》）
Coming up, two people who succeed at getting something for nothing, big time, and the consequences. That's in a minute when our program continues.
接下来的节目，两个成功实现不劳而获的人，以及随之而来的后果。稍后节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a wide variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Something for Nothing. Stories of people who try to make easy money and what happens when they try. As everybody knows, you usually pay a price, some price.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你各种各样关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“不劳而获”。关于人们试图赚快钱的故事，以及当他们尝试时会发生什么。正如每个人所知，你通常要付出代价，某种代价。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program, Tao of the Dumpster. This is the story of Dirk Jamison's dad, a man who decided to seek something for nothing, mostly for his own pleasure, mostly for his own self-interest. But one thing that's interesting about this is that one consequence of him doing it is that he ends up a better dad, arguably, arguably. In fact, the family does argue about it.
我们进入了节目的第三幕，“垃圾桶里的道”。这是德克·贾米森父亲的故事，一个决定寻找不劳而获的机会的人，主要是为了他自己的乐趣，主要是为了他自己的私利。但有趣的一点是，他这样做的一个后果是，他最终成了一个更好的父亲，可以说，可以说。事实上，家人确实为此争论过。
Dad wasn't always in the trash. But by 1976, life had gone into an ugly holding pattern and nothing was adding up. He was counting weeks like he used to count days. To Dad, my mother was a pining walrus wrapped in polyester who couldn't take a single sentence at face value. If he said two words, she heard five or six. And they scalded her guts.
爸爸并不总是翻垃圾。但到了1976年，生活陷入了一种丑陋的僵局，一切都不顺心。他像数日子一样数着周。对爸爸来说，我母亲是一个穿着聚酯纤维衣服、沉溺于忧郁的象海象，她无法从字面上理解任何句子。他如果说两个词，她能听出五六个。而且那些话烫伤了她的肠子。
He once gave her a soap-on-a-rope in the shape of an aspirin because she swallowed handfuls at night in order to sleep. But she considered this over-sized pill a vicious hint that Dad wanted her to go to sleep for good. In a crowded mall, Dad let go of a door and it nailed her in the forehead. She stunned cheery Christmas shoppers with a high-decibel accusation. Her husband was trying to kill her with doors.
他曾经送给她一块阿司匹林形状的绳上香皂，因为她晚上为了入睡吞下一把药丸。但她认为这颗特大号药丸是一个恶毒的暗示，暗示爸爸想让她彻底长眠。在一个拥挤的商场里，爸爸松开了门，门正好撞在她的额头上。她用高分贝的指控让那些快乐的圣诞购物者震惊不已。她丈夫正试图用门杀了她。
We kids made him happy, gorging on hot dogs and pancakes paid for by his hammer-and-nailing. But that didn't make a life. So he made a decision. He'd move us to Mammoth Lakes and teach us to ski. Screw all that empty labor and alienation. We would hike and have a serious blast, catch rainbow trout, and go sledding, and have snowball fights. All he had to do was get fired. Unemployment and food stamps would carry us through the winter. So he began a campaign to lose his construction job. He ignored his pouch of nails. He lounged. He made idle chat. He was fired.
我们这些孩子让他感到快乐，沉溺于他靠敲敲打打赚来的钱买的热狗和煎饼。但那不成生活。所以他做了一个决定。他要搬家到猛犸湖，教我们滑雪。去他妈的空洞劳动和疏离。我们要徒步旅行，尽情享受，钓虹鳟鱼，去滑雪橇，打雪仗。他要做的就是被解雇。失业救济金和食品券会让我们熬过冬天。所以他开始了一项失去建筑工工作的行动。他无视他的钉子袋。他懒散。他闲聊。他被解雇了。
After being laid off, Dad went straight to the supermarket for moving boxes, but instead found an old man grinning from inside the dumpster like a euphoric half-wit, eating cold spaghetti from a can. His face was covered with grime, and his teeth had rotted down to brown spikes. But Dad thought he was the happiest person he'd seen in years. He wanted to share his score with Dad. Some nice chicken, broccoli, mangoes, a mystery novel, and a bag of hard candy, most of which was going to his 60-year-old girlfriend waiting in a nearby trailer park.
被解雇后，爸爸直接去超市找搬家纸箱，但却发现一个老人正从垃圾桶里露出一张狂喜的傻瓜般的笑脸，吃着罐头里的冷意大利面。他的脸被污垢覆盖，牙齿烂成了棕色的尖刺。但爸爸觉得他是他多年来见过最快乐的人。他想和爸爸分享他的战利品。一些不错的鸡肉、西兰花、芒果、一本神秘小说，还有一袋硬糖，其中大部分是要给他住在附近拖车公园里60岁的女朋友的。
"Very important to share." He offered Dad the chicken. "Plenty to go around and just thrown out that morning. All wrapped up tight in plastic. No worse than day-old bread. And Lord knows, the price is right." Dad got the hell out of there. But he spent the entire afternoon thinking about it, even took a half-assed shot at discussing it with Mom. That old guy had looked more relaxed and content, hip-deep in dregs, than Dad could remember ever feeling. Trashing made money obsolete. No reason to pay for food. It waits out back the same as on the shelf.
“分享非常重要。”他把鸡肉递给爸爸。“很多吃的，只是那天早上被扔掉了。都用塑料袋包得严严实实的。不比隔夜面包差。上帝知道，价格还合适。”爸爸赶紧离开了那里。但他整个下午都在思考这件事，甚至试图和妈妈讨论。那个老人在垃圾堆里显得比爸爸记忆中他自己所感受到的任何时候都要放松和满足。翻垃圾让钱变得多余。没有理由花钱买食物。它在后面等着，就像在货架上一样。
Mom was mortified. It was ludicrous to be envious of a homeless person. Freedom meant choices, and that old guy had none. But Dad had plenty and should be making something of his life instead of thinking low-class thoughts. Dad went back first thing in the morning. He watched an aproned kid carry out a gallon jar of pickled eggs like a football. And the passage from in to out was crystal clear. Nothing about the eggs had changed. But in 30 seconds, the jar had been transformed from top-notch product into utter swill.
妈妈惊呆了。羡慕一个无家可归的人真是荒谬。自由意味着选择，而那个人没有任何选择。但爸爸拥有很多，应该在生活中有所作为，而不是想些低俗的想法。爸爸第二天一早又去了。他看着一个系着围裙的孩子像抱橄榄球一样抱出一加仑罐装腌蛋。从里面到外面的过程一清二楚。鸡蛋本身没变。但30秒内，那罐腌蛋就从顶级产品变成了彻头彻尾的泔水。
Dad went over just for a look and found a split-open, 50-pound bag of dry dog food. Perfect initiation. He could test the water without sticking anything in his mouth. He could climb in for a loyal family dog and save the $5 her food cost every week. A few minutes in the dumpster would equal 5 smackers. That was about $100 an hour. He climbed in and spotted the jar, expiration date one day passed, lid snug. He opened it, the dumpster suddenly feeling like half foxhole-half goldmine, and hesitated only long enough to smell the top egg, then wolfed it down. Delicious.
爸爸走过去只是看了一眼，就发现了一袋裂开的50磅重的干狗粮。完美的入门。他可以测试一下水深，而不用往嘴里塞任何东西。他可以为一个忠诚的家狗爬进去，省下每周5美元的狗粮钱。在垃圾桶里待几分钟就等于5块钱。那大约是每小时100美元。他爬进去，发现了那个罐子，过期一天，盖子盖得很紧。他打开它，垃圾桶突然感觉像是一半掩体一半金矿，他只在闻了闻最上面那个蛋后犹豫了片刻，然后狼吞虎咽地吃掉了。美味。
He sped home, and fed the dog, and tried to pass out the eggs. But Mom was glaring at the menacing, felt-tip X marked in the jar lid. "That better not be what I think it is," she said, "so help me god."
他飞车回家，喂了狗，并试图分发鸡蛋。但妈妈正盯着罐子盖上那个威胁性的毡尖笔画的X。“那最好不是我想的那样，”她说，“上帝帮帮我。”
Dad opened his mouth to deny it, but froze. "OK, fine," he said, deciding to try to be himself even if his wife didn't want him to. "It's trash."
爸爸张开嘴想否认，但僵住了。“好吧，好吧，”他说，决定尝试做回自己，即使他妻子不想让他这样。“那是垃圾。”
Mom stomped into the bedroom, and Dad followed. He said he finally understood what he'd been doing with his life. He'd been working for furniture, and new shoes, and magazine subscriptions, making petty habits a priority and handing authority to some persona, who he thought he should be instead of who he was. But those eggs were undeniable. More trash meant less work. Less work meant more time and, finally, more life. Think of it. They could do whatever the hell they wanted. No work. Just skiing, sledding, snowballs, food stamps.
妈妈跺脚进了卧室，爸爸跟了进去。他说他终于明白他一生都在干什么了。他一直在为家具、新鞋和杂志订阅而工作，把琐碎的习惯当作优先事项，并把权力交给了一个他以为自己应该是的人，而不是他自己。但那些鸡蛋是不可否认的。更多的垃圾意味着更少的工作。更少的工作意味着更多的时间，最后，更多的生活。想想看。他们可以做任何他们想做的混蛋事。不用工作。只有滑雪、雪橇、雪球、食品券。
"No." Mom despised food stamps. People snickered in line, and checkers were condescending. Her father had raised 10 children and never once resorted to crummy welfare or scavenging. But she was missing the point. So Dad spoke slowly. "I don't want to waste any more days at all." Mom smothered herself with a pillow and blurted, "I won't do it." In three weeks, we would leave for Mammoth Mountain in California.
“不。”妈妈鄙视食品券。人们在排队时窃笑，收银员也很傲慢。她父亲抚养了10个孩子，从未求助于蹩脚的救济或拾荒。但她错过了重点。所以爸爸慢慢地说。“我不想再浪费任何日子了。”妈妈用枕头把自己捂住，脱口而出：“我不会做的。”三周后，我们将搬到加利福尼亚的猛犸山。
Dad had heard that Mammoth had the most square footage of terrifying slope in the country. Pine sap smelled like vanilla. And for $250 a month, we could live four miles below some 30 ski lifts and a space-age gondola that raced to nose-bleed altitudes and stopped at a cafeteria halfway down the run, where everyone collapsed and refueled on corned beef and cabbage and steins of beer.
爸爸听说猛犸山拥有全国最恐怖的滑雪道。松树液闻起来像香草。而且每个月只需250美元，我们就能住在离30部滑雪缆车和一部时速飞快、冲向高海拔的太空时代缆车下方四英里处，缆车停在跑道中途的自助餐厅，每个人都在那里瘫倒，用粗盐腌牛肉和卷心菜以及大杯啤酒补充体力。
Our house was an A-frame crowded by wild Christmas trees. And on the very day we moved in, a fish hatchery truck backed down our driveway to stock the backyard creek with brook trout. "Talk about a good omen," Dad said.
我们的房子是一个被野生圣诞树包围的A型屋。就在我们搬进去的那天，一辆鱼苗车倒车开进了我们的车道，向后院的小溪里投放了溪鳟鱼。“真是个好兆头，”爸爸说。
There was no time to locate fishing rods. We just blitzed in and started groping. And Dad cheered from the bank. My first fish ever was 12 inches long and nabbed with cold, bare hands. I raised it over my head, and we were all screaming.
没时间找鱼竿了。我们只是冲进去，开始摸鱼。爸爸在岸上欢呼。我的第一条鱼有12英寸长，是用冷冰冰的赤手抓到的。我把它举过头顶，我们都尖叫起来。
At first, husband and wife shopped together. Mom headed for the electric doors, clutching those dreaded food stamps. And Dad called out, "The adventure's in back, Babe." He views this as a whole-hearted invitation, but even now, there's a taunting edge to his voice that he doesn't acknowledge.
起初，夫妻俩一起去购物。妈妈走向电子门，紧紧攥着那些可怕的食品券。爸爸大声喊道：“冒险在后面，宝贝。”他把这看作是一个全心全意的邀请，但即使是现在，他声音里依然有一种他不承认的嘲讽意味。
The amount of food being cast out in Mammoth was astounding. The economy was tourist-driven, and fancy skiers preferred high-class eats. So the instant a piece of fruit showed age, it was ditched. Dad scored racks of papayas so ripe, they were oozing and split. If the corner of a cereal box got crunched, managers considered the cereal inside irrelevant. If a manager needed shelf space for granola bars and trail mix, he abandoned a slow seller. And Dad lugged home crates of onion-flavored potato chips, unfresh bagels, a dozen cottage cheeses. Finding enough to feed a family of five was a breeze. But afterward, when he wanted to compare hauls, mom looked at him with disdain and kept her bags away from his, afraid of contamination, setting her prediction of his death by poisoning at two weeks.
在猛犸市丢弃的食物量令人震惊。经济是旅游驱动的，有钱的滑雪者更喜欢高档饮食。所以只要水果出现老化的迹象，它就会被扔掉。爸爸收获了成排的木瓜，熟得都要溢出来裂开了。如果麦片盒的一角被挤压了，经理们就认为里面的麦片无关紧要了。如果经理需要货架空间放格兰诺拉麦片棒和什锦干果，他就会抛弃销量慢的产品。爸爸拖回家几箱洋葱味的薯片、不新鲜的贝果、一打奶酪。找到足够的食物喂一家五口是轻而易举的事。但事后，当他想比较战利品时，妈妈对他投以蔑视，把她的包远离他的，害怕污染，并预测他在两周内就会中毒身亡。
She warned us about the bins. Dad was immune to the filth because selfishness and spiritual corruption had made him thick-skinned. But we were angelic and frail, and might suffocate on the stink. Or worse, slip and bash our heads. Then literally drown in two inches of immoral muck. She said trash was a horrible thing, but it was difficult for us to believe. Dad was having big fun. And one thing children seem to understand, fun is not horrible.
她警告我们远离垃圾箱。爸爸对那种肮脏免疫，因为自私和精神腐败让他脸皮厚了。但我们天使般又脆弱，可能会被恶臭窒息。或者更糟，滑倒撞破头。然后真的溺死在两英寸不道德的泥泞中。她说垃圾是可怕的东西，但我们很难相信。爸爸玩得非常开心。孩子们似乎明白一件事，开心绝不可怕。
Mom declared the refrigerator off-limits. Dad found an old fridge and stashed his booty in the garage. Mom banned trashing at her favorite stores, so Dad sneaked out at night and hid convenience desserts under our pillows. Mom found licked-clean pudding cartons and forbade us to eat "that." Dad picked us up from school, and we hit candy stores and pastry shops on the sly.
妈妈宣布冰箱禁止存放垃圾食物。爸爸找到一个旧冰箱，把他的战利品藏在车库里。妈妈禁止在他的心头好店翻垃圾，所以爸爸晚上偷偷溜出去，把便利店的甜点藏在我们的枕头下。妈妈发现了舔得干干净净的布丁盒，禁止我们吃“那个”。爸爸从学校接我们，我们偷偷摸摸地去糖果店和糕点店。
"Jackpot" became the code word when my sister found a jumbo pack of Twinkies designed to be carried like a backpack. She ran at top speed with a tube of decorative crepe paper, flailing her arms and sprinting a huge circle back to the Twinkies. The red paper unraveled behind her like a parade streamer. We made ourselves sick, cramming all of the Twinkies in the drive home, then laid around the house and groaned.
当我的姐姐找到一包像背包一样携带的超大包装的Twinkies时，“大奖”成了我们的暗号。她挥舞着一卷装饰用的皱纹纸，挥动手臂，绕着Twinkies跑了一个大圈。红色的纸像游行用的彩带一样在她身后散开。我们把自己吃吐了，在回家路上拼命塞进Twinkies，然后躺在屋里呻吟。
Mom put two and two together, then staged a protest. She wouldn't speak again until her children were garbage free. She wouldn't do a single chore. For a week, we saw her only twice a day. Straight to her room after work and stomping out to the car in the morning. Dad prepared all-trash meals. A sourdough culture thrived in a Mason jar above the stove. Dad mixed it in his second-hand flour and made humongous stacks of pancakes, referred to as "gooners," smothered with coconut syrup from behind the health food store. "Who wants gooners?" he would shout. "Me, me, me."
妈妈把两件事联系在一起，然后发起了抗议。在她的孩子们不再吃垃圾食物之前，她不会再说话。她不会做一件家务。一周里，我们每天只见到她两次。下班后直奔房间，早上跺着脚走向车子。爸爸准备了所有的垃圾餐。一个酸面团菌种在炉子上方的一个梅森罐里繁衍。爸爸把它混入他二手的面粉里，做了巨大的煎饼堆，被称为“傻蛋饼”，上面涂着从健康食品店后面拿来的椰子糖浆。“谁想要傻蛋饼？”他会大喊。“我，我，我。”
Mom packed her bags. She gathered us at the door to explain that Dad was a heartless son of a bitch whom she couldn't stand for another second. But she would come visit us on the weekends. And we could stay with her. "Whatever you want," she said. "It's up to you." We begged her to stay. We got on our knees and gradually convinced her that life would be pointless and crappy without her. And as she unpacked, I sobbed with relief. But when she packed again in four days, we barely glanced up from the television. And from then on, she had to convince herself to stick around.
妈妈打包了行李。她把我们聚在门口，解释说爸爸是个没心没肺的混蛋，她一秒钟都忍不下去了。但她会在周末来看我们。我们可以和她待在一起。“随你们怎么想，”她说。“这取决于你们。”我们求她留下来。我们跪在地上，逐渐说服她，没有她，生活将毫无意义且糟糕透顶。当她拆开行李时，我因解脱而啜泣。但四天后她再次打包时，我们几乎没有从电视上移开视线。从那时起，她不得不说服自己留下来。
I end up calling Mom to ask her about those years. She's a little perturbed by my questions. Why do I take such an interest in Dad when he's always been such a selfish jerk? She was the one. She was there for us. She paid the bills and kept the heat on. She crawled under the house and unfroze the pipes when Dad went on his damn winter vacations to Baja. She worked really hard for Christmases and new clothes for school. Dad only did whatever the hell he wanted. But he always got the credit for being such a great father.
我最终打电话给妈妈问她那几年的事。她对我的问题有点不安。为什么我对爸爸那么感兴趣，而他一直是个自私的混蛋？她是那个人。她为了我们存在。她支付账单并保持供暖。当爸爸去巴哈度寒假时，她爬到房下解冻水管。她为圣诞节和学校的新衣服努力工作。爸爸只做任何他想做的混蛋事。但他总是因为是一个伟大的父亲而受到赞誉。
And now I'm writing a book about him? Why? What did he do to deserve all this attention? She says, "He has less freedom than any man I've ever known. He can't go where he wants because he can't spend anything to get what he wants. He has to go worst class because he's not free enough to part with a dollar."
现在我正在写一本关于他的书？为什么？他做了什么值得所有这些关注的事？她说：“他比我认识的任何男人都缺乏自由。他不能去他想去的地方，因为他不能花钱去得到他想要的东西。他必须走最差的路，因为他不自由，舍不得花一美元。”
She's on the verge of crying now, but contains herself long enough to recount some bitter family folklore, husband eats heart of watermelon. "Now with me," she says, "I would cut a piece off. And everyone would have a piece. Burt's way was to cut down the middle and eat the heart out because that's the part he wanted. I said, 'But Burt, that's the best part. And you should only take your share of the best part.' But he said, 'No, I take what I want.'"
她现在快要哭了，但忍住了，足够说出一些痛苦的家庭传说：丈夫吃西瓜心。“如果是我的话，”她说，“我会切下一块。每个人都会有一块。伯特的做法是把西瓜切开，把西瓜心吃了，因为那是他想要的部分。我说：‘但伯特，那是最好的一部分。你只应该拿属于你那份最好的部分。’但他却说：‘不，我拿我想要的。’”
She warned him. "Do it again, and you'll be sorry." He did it again. So she grabbed the gutted melon and went after him. "I threw it and hit him right on the head on the apartment steps. As with most things, I didn't put my foot down soon enough. I just kept thinking he was going to evolve, that these weirdnesses in him were going to change. But it got worse instead of better. From the person I married to the person I divorced 20 years later, I couldn't recognize anything in that man."
她警告他。“再做一次，你会后悔的。”他又做了一次。所以她抓起掏空的西瓜追他去了。“我扔了出去，正好砸在他公寓台阶上的头上。像大多数事情一样，我没有足够早地采取强硬态度。我一直以为他会进化，他身上的这些怪癖会改变。但结果不仅没变好反而更糟了。从我嫁的那个人到20年后我离婚的那个人，我对他再也认不出什么了。”
Later, I asked Dad about the watermelon. "I wanted her to experience that same thing I did," he said. "You've got this really great part. I wanted her to experience the heart of life, I guess, or the heart of the watermelon. You give yourself that gift. You give yourself a gift of what happens. And that's what makes life worthwhile."
后来，我问爸爸关于西瓜的事。“我希望她能体验到我和我一样的经历，”他说。“你有这个很棒的部分。我想让她体验生活的核心，我想，或者是西瓜的核心。你给了自己那份礼物。你给了自己一份关于发生了什么事的礼物。这就是让生活值得的原因。”
"What'd she say?" I ask.
“她说什么？”我问。
"When I ate the heart? She was upset. She ran after me, and she threw it at me. I ran down the stairs. She threw it after me. But I got another watermelon. And I said, 'Now I want you to eat the heart.' But she wouldn't do it. I said, 'This is for you. You eat the heart.' If I cut it out and gave it to her, she couldn't eat it. She said, 'I can't. I can't eat the heart.' She didn't think she deserved it."
“当我吃西瓜心的时候？她很生气。她追着我，把西瓜扔向我。我跑下楼梯。她扔在我身后。但我又拿了一个西瓜。我说：‘现在我要你吃西瓜心。’但她不肯。我说：‘这是给你的。你吃西瓜心。’如果我切下来给她，她也吃不下。她说：‘我不能。我吃不下西瓜心。’她不认为她配得上它。”
"So what did you do then?" I ask.
“那你后来怎么做了？”我问。
"I don't know." He breaks into a big laugh. "I may have eaten the heart."
“我不知道。”他大笑起来。“我可能自己把心给吃了。”
Years ago, Dad was handing out mini jugs of orange juice when my sister spotted a boy from grade school, staring from his bicycle at the far end of the lot. Her expression made Dad think she'd cut her finger or smashed a toe. She ducked behind the dumpster and hissed, "I know him," eventually confessing to Mom that she had a crush on the boy. When he ridiculed her at recess, she sucker punched him in the throat and was suspended from fifth grade for three days.
多年前，爸爸正在分发迷你装橙汁，我姐姐发现一个小学同学正从停车场尽头的自行车上盯着她看。她的表情让爸爸以为她切了手指或砸了脚趾。她躲在垃圾桶后面发出嘶嘶声，“我认识他”，最终向妈妈承认她暗恋那个男孩。当他在课间休息时嘲笑她时，她猛地打了他的喉咙，并被五年级停课三天。
She refused to leave her room. So Mom carried in favorite dinners on a big platter. Dad wanted to talk her through it, but took the wrong approach, suggesting she see shame as a concept and not just a feeling. It was replacement emotion, like anger, he said. We used it when we couldn't distinguish exactly how we felt. Dad drilled her with thematics, but was simply attaching a stigma to her reaction by implying that her feelings weren't real. So he finally shut up.
她拒绝离开房间。所以妈妈用一个大盘子把最喜欢的晚餐端进去。爸爸想和她谈谈，但采取了错误的方法，建议她把羞耻看作一个概念而不是仅仅一种感觉。他说，这是一种替代性的情绪，就像愤怒。当我们无法准确辨别自己的感受时，我们就会用到它。爸爸用主题训练她，却通过暗示她的感受不真实来给她的反应贴上耻辱的标签。所以他最终闭嘴了。
He tried to empathize instead. He squatted in dumpsters and pictured the person he'd least like to see him there. An old girlfriend, the president, John Wayne. He tried to humiliate himself, but couldn't. So he sat down again with my sister and tried to be on her side this time. If her heart hurt, hey, that's all that mattered. She should go for it, he said, feel as ashamed as she wanted. Shame held significance for her, obviously. So the only way to figure it out was to, as he said, take it to the limit. She said, "I don't want anymore trash, Dad."
他试着感同身受。他在垃圾桶里蹲着，想象他最不想看到他在这里的人。前女友，总统，约翰·韦恩。他试图羞辱自己，但没成功。所以他再次和我姐姐坐下来，这次试着站在她这边。如果她的心痛了，嘿，那才是唯一重要的事。她说，她应该去尝试，想觉得多羞耻就多羞耻。显然，羞耻对她来说有重要意义。所以弄清楚的唯一办法就是，正如他说的，把它发挥到极致。她说：“我再也不要垃圾了，爸爸。”
I remind Dad of how, when we were young, he would spend an entire day playing with us. But he would never spend time making money if we wanted something.
我提醒爸爸，当我们年轻时，他会花一整天和我们一起玩。但如果我们要什么东西，他绝不会花时间去赚钱。
"Well," he said, "the things that money could buy are not of great value. To me, love is a giving of time and attention. That's a real gift. Money's not a gift. It just gives you things. And they're OK. But they're not of primary importance. Money's OK. It's another adventure. So you go on the money adventure. How far can you go? You get a yacht or whatever people do with a lot of money. But then what do you do? Are you really happy? You've still got to do something with life. There's a certain searching. Everybody's curious and looking. You see people looking everywhere. What are they looking for? I think it's right in front them. Right there. The thing itself."
“嗯，”他说，“钱能买到的东西价值不高。对我来说，爱是时间和注意力的付出。那才是真正的礼物。钱不是礼物。它只是给你东西。它们还可以。但它们不是最重要的。钱还好。那是另一场冒险。所以你去冒险赚钱。你能走多远？你买一艘游艇或者是人们有钱时做的任何事。但然后呢？你真的快乐吗？你还是得用生活做点什么。有一种某种探索。每个人都很好奇，都在寻找。你看到人们到处寻找。他们在找什么？我想就在他们面前。就在那儿。东西本身。”
"What is it?" I ask.
“它是什么？”我问。
He laughs. "Hell if I know."
他笑了。“鬼知道。”
Dirk Jamison's story Tao of the Dumpster first appeared in the LA Weekly. He's also made a film about the subject. And he has a book about his childhood called Perishable: A Memoir.
德克·贾米森的《垃圾桶里的道》首先发表在《洛杉矶周刊》上。他也拍摄了一部关于这个主题的电影。他还有一本关于他童年的书叫《易腐：回忆录》。
[MUSIC - "BUSTED" BY WACO BROTHERS]
（音乐 - 韦科兄弟的《被抓》）
Act Four, Another Success Story. Well, Hollywood is our national capital of something for nothing and our dream of something for nothing. And of course, anybody who's ever seen any of those movies about Hollywood-- Barton Fink, A Star is Born, Day of the Locust-- anybody who's seen them knows that the classic story of something for nothing is about the price that you pay once you make your easy money, once you make your big kill. So with that in mind, we will end our program today with a variation on that theme from writer Sandra Tsing Loh in Los Angeles.
第四幕，另一个成功的故事。好吧，好莱坞是我们不劳而获的国家首都，也是我们不劳而获的梦想。当然，任何看过那些关于好莱坞电影的人——《巴顿·芬克》、《一个明星的诞生》、《蝗虫之日》——任何看过这些电影的人都知道，关于不劳而获的经典故事是关于一旦你赚到快钱，一旦你实现大赢后所付出的代价。考虑到这一点，我们今天用洛杉矶作家桑德拉·清·洛提供的那个主题的变体来结束我们的节目。
Do I believe in the magic of Disney? Yes, I do. One day, my friend Roger Cox was a 40-something, underemployed, actor, director, pet sitter. The next, he blossomed into a veritable industry mini-mogul, sporting capped teeth, brand new Isuzu Trooper, even health insurance. Sound miraculous? Cinderella-esque? Late '80s? It is. And it could only have happened in Glendale at the Walt Disney Corporation.
我相信迪斯尼的魔法吗？是的，我相信。有一天，我的朋友罗杰·考克斯还是一位40多岁、就业不足、演员、导演、宠物保姆。下一刻，他成了一个真正的行业微型大亨，戴着烤瓷牙，开着全新的五十铃 Trooper，甚至有了健康保险。听起来很神奇？辛德瑞拉式的？80年代末？确实如此。而且这只能发生在格伦代尔的沃尔特迪斯尼公司。
The story begins in a little, ramshackle bungalow sans air conditioning in Pasadena. The year is 1985. Our hero has just stepped off the plane from New York, penniless, with only a duffel bag. LA is a place where appearances mean a lot. And let us just say that in fall 1985, Roger does not look like a person who will soon be playing tennis in Encino. He is 41 going on 70, a battered 5 foot 3. A root-beer dwarf is his self-description. A chain smoker, a lousy dresser, and has bad knees.
故事开始于帕萨迪纳的一栋简陋、没有空调的小平房里。那是1985年。我们的英雄刚从纽约下飞机，身无分文，只有一个行李袋。洛杉矶是一个外表很重要的城市。让我们说在1985年秋天，罗杰看起来不像一个很快就会在恩西诺打网球的人。他41岁，看起来像70岁，个子娇小，只有5英尺3英寸。他自称是“根啤酒矮人”。一个老烟枪，穿衣品味糟糕，膝盖不好。
Equity Waiver Theater can be a cruel mistress. And after 35, she can inflict a certain darkness of spirit. "She takes all your money and, after a while, won't even [BLEEP] you anymore," as my friend Mel says. Because 35 is an age when even the most die-hard bohemian begins to wish for life's little luxuries, one's own futon to sleep on, liability car insurance, dental care. Roger has none of these things, so add to the appearance a somewhat negative life outlook. But this is all soon to change. How is almost Hans-Christian-Andersen-esque.
“股权豁免剧院”可能是一个残酷的情妇。35岁之后，她会给你的灵魂带来某种黑暗。“她拿走你所有的钱，过了一段时间，甚至都不会再和你[哔]了，”正如我的朋友梅尔所说。因为35岁是一个即使最坚定的波西米亚人也开始渴望生活中的小奢侈的年纪，拥有自己的榻榻米睡觉，有责任保险，有牙科护理。罗杰什么都没有，所以除了外表，还要加上一种有些消极的人生观。但这很快就要改变了。过程几乎是安徒生式的。
Fast forward to 1987. Roger is tapped to direct an original play in a not-untypical, 77-seat LA run. That is, six weeks of rehearsal culminating in one weekend of performance. Meanwhile, someone loses $6,000, there are no reviews, and frantic efforts to videotape it at some tiny college in Pomona with hostile student cameramen come to nothing. The final insult? Monday morning, Roger, the director, is forced to drive all the props and furniture back himself.
快进到1987年。罗杰被聘请执导一部原创剧，在洛杉矶77个座位的剧场演出。也就是说，六周的排练，最终只有一个周末的表演。与此同时，有人赔了6000美元，没有评论，在波莫纳的一所小学院里，带着敌意的学生摄像师拼命录像，结果什么也没留下。最后的侮辱？周一早上，导演罗杰被迫自己开车把所有的道具和家具拉回去。
Picture it. There our hero sits on a blazing Monday morning-- and how cruel those LA Monday mornings are-- at a stoplight, Western and Santa Monica, in his uninsured '79 Honda Civic. But then something makes Roger look to his left. And there, gesturing at him madly, is a well-groomed woman in a cream-colored Audi.
想象一下。我们的英雄坐在一个灼热的周一早上——洛杉矶的周一早上是多么残酷——在西大道和圣莫尼卡的红绿灯前，开着他那辆没有保险的79年本田思域。但这时有什么东西让罗杰看向他的左边。在那里，一个穿着奶油色奥迪的妆容精致的女人正疯狂地向他招手。
"Roger!" she calls out. He rolls down his window. "John is in town. He wants you to call him." A phone number is hurled into the shuddering Honda, followed by the screech of Audi tires.
“罗杰！”她喊道。他摇下车窗。“约翰在城里。他想让你给他打电话。”一个电话号码被抛进颤抖的思域车里，接着是奥迪轮胎刺耳的刹车声。
One week later, boom! Roger is hired by Disney. And why not? Disney's amusement park division is expanding, expanding, expanding. They are building up Disneyworld in Orlando like crazy. Next is Euro Disney. Then there's Japan. They need creative thinkers. Roger is suddenly drawing $60,000 a year, perhaps four times what he's seen in those 40-odd years. Job description? Imagineer.
一周后，砰！罗杰被迪斯尼雇用了。为什么不呢？迪斯尼的游乐园部门正在扩张，扩张，扩张。他们正在奥兰多疯狂建设迪士尼乐园。下一个是欧洲迪斯尼。然后是日本。他们需要创意思想者。罗杰突然获得了每年6万美元的收入，也许是他那40多年来看过的钱的四倍。职位描述？幻想工程师。
"Roger thinks up rides for amusement parks," I would tell other bohos, semi-employed 30-somethings, active in their various part-time songwriting, freelance recording engineer, jewelry design, $8 an hour word processing, unpublished novelist, studio-based trombone, pot-selling industries. "Wow," such creative types respond, their eyes glazing over. And at the end of the evening, Roger would unfailingly pick up the check. His triumphal cry? "It's on the mouse."
“罗杰负责构思游乐园的游乐设施，”我会告诉其他波西米亚人，那些半就业的30多岁的人，在他们各种兼职歌曲创作、自由录音工程师、珠宝设计、每小时8美元的文字处理、未发表的小说家、录音室长号、卖大麻等行业中活跃的人。“哇，”这种创意型人才回答，他们的眼神变得空洞。而晚上结束时，罗杰总是会买单。他的凯旋呼喊？“算在鼠标头上了。”
Roger came to have a dapper new look, too. Once on the Disney lot-- where you meet a better class of people anyway-- he had almost immediately met a fine new woman named Donna, who made it her mission to get the Tweeds catalog and buy Roger everything out of it. Soon Roger is resplendent in safari khakis, and beige linens, and crisp, white shirts.
罗杰也焕然一新，有了时髦的新面貌。一旦进入迪斯尼地盘——反正你会遇到更高级的人——他几乎立刻就遇到了一个叫唐娜的精明新女人，她把获取《Tweeds》目录并给罗杰购买其中的一切作为自己的使命。很快，罗杰就穿上了游猎卡其布、米色亚麻布和清爽的白衬衫。
He trades in the Civic for a Trooper. The hair is permed. Teeth are capped. New glasses are purchased. Roger begins to look positively sleek. In his Equity Waiver days, he used to call industry scouts, with great derision, "the IJS," which stood for "Important Jewish Suits." Now he is one. He quits smoking. He pays off some 20-odd-years of debt. Roger begins to hire his poorer artistic friends for Walt Disney imagineering gigs. He is Solomon, dispensing coins to the peasants.
他把思域换成了Trooper。头发烫了。牙齿烤瓷了。买了新眼镜。罗杰看起来相当时髦。在他“股权豁免”的日子里，他过去常带着巨大的嘲笑称行业星探为“IJS”，意思是“重要的犹太西装”。现在他自己也是其中之一。他戒烟了。他偿还了20多年累积的债务。罗杰开始雇佣他更贫穷的艺术朋友参加华特迪士尼幻想工程的演出。他是所罗门，给农民发钱。
Voice-overs flow from him. A music score for a three-minute, in-house film. $100 checks for two hours of concept consulting. Roger is absolutely in his element. Never was a job so suited to a person. Calls wore in from him Monday morning. "Asia," he exclaims in stentorian tones. "What do you find fascinating about Asia? Go." Apparently, this week's task is to think up rides based on the continents. But why stop there? Next week, his assignment is "The universe. Go."
配音工作源源不断。一部三分钟的内部电影的配乐。为两个小时的概念咨询支付100美元的支票。罗杰完全处于他的元素中。从来没有一份工作如此适合一个人。周一早上他的电话就打过来了。“亚洲，”他用洪亮的声音惊叹。“关于亚洲你觉得什么最吸引人？开始。”显然，本周的任务是构思基于各大洲的游乐设施。但为什么止步于此？下周，他的任务是“宇宙。开始。”
But then the tide turns. Was it an angry look from Michael Eisner? One bloated Visa bill too many? A bad dream about a mouse? "Ayenbite of Inwyt" is Roger's three-word explanation. And when a Disney person begins quoting Joyce, that is the point where you know you will soon be paying for your own drinks.
但随后风向变了。那是迈克尔·艾斯纳生气的眼神吗？一张过度的维萨卡账单？关于一只老鼠的噩梦？“良知的悔恨”是罗杰三个词的解释。当一个迪斯尼人开始引用乔伊斯的诗句时，那就是你知道你很快就得自己买酒喝的时候。
Roger begins staying in over the weekend, reading Nietzsche, Boll, books about the Grand Guignol Theater. Ask him how Asia and his close friend Jeffrey Katzenberg are doing, and one gets only a curt response. "I'm tired of writing for robots." In the next breath, Roger goes into a wild tirade. Excitedly, he outlines his new project. To perform "Crap's Last Tape" in the Theatre Theater toilet, pants down around his ankles, for three people. He is smoking again.
罗杰开始周末待在家里，读尼采、伯尔，关于大吉尼奥尔剧院的书。问他亚洲和他的好朋友杰弗里·卡森伯格进展如何，得到的只有一个生硬的回应。“我厌倦了为机器人写作。”在下一刻，罗杰进行了一场疯狂的抨击。他兴奋地概述了他的新项目。在剧场剧院的厕所里表演《克拉普的最后录音带》，裤子脱到脚踝，给三个人看。他又开始抽烟了。
You know he's finally gone over the edge when he tells you he is thinking of designing a new amusement park concept called "Crap Land." Here, terrible crap happens to people and uniformed Craplanders cheerfully abuse them. Fortunately for Roger, the world economy turns. And soon the amusement park industry is to go into a little bit of a bust. In short, in summer 1992, the unthinkable happens. Disney lays off some 400 of its 500 imagineers. Even though, oddly, the construction of new buildings and wings continues apace.
你知道他终于崩溃了，当他告诉你他在考虑设计一个叫“垃圾乐园”的新游乐园概念时。在这里，糟糕的垃圾事发生在人们身上，穿制服的垃圾乐园人愉快地虐待他们。幸运的是对罗杰来说，世界经济好转了。很快游乐园行业进入了一点小低谷。简而言之，1992年夏天，不可思议的事情发生了。迪斯尼解雇了500名幻想工程师中的约400名。尽管奇怪的是，新建筑和新区的建设依然在继续。
The nightmare is over. Roger is free again. He is at peace. After all, he's had five great years, thanks to his corporate fairy godmother. His debts are paid off. He's got a terrific wardrobe. He has money in the bank. He's got contacts both in his address book and in his eyes. He can collect unemployment now. Do nothing but dream for a year. For a guy who came here with nothing, that's pretty good.
噩梦结束了。罗杰又自由了。他平静了。毕竟，多亏了他的企业教母，他度过了辉煌的五年。他的债务还清了。他有了一套很棒的衣柜。他银行里有钱。他的通讯录里和眼睛里都有人脉。他现在可以领失业救济金了。一年里除了做梦什么都不用做。对于一个什么都没有来到这里的人来说，那已经很不错了。
Sandra Tsing Loh. Her most recent book, Mother On Fire, came out this month. Her friend Roger died last year.
桑德拉·清·洛。她最近的书《着火的母亲》本月出版。她的朋友罗杰去年去世了。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Paul Tough, Nancy Updike, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors for this show Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and P.J. Vogt. Music help today from John Connors.
嗯，我们今天的节目是由艾里克斯·斯皮格尔和我自己制作的，还有保罗·塔夫、南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德。本节目的特约编辑是莎拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。阿德里安·马蒂奥韦茨负责我们的网站。塞思·林德和P.J.沃格特提供了制作帮助。约翰·康纳斯提供了今天的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助名录）
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's always walking up to us in the hallway, standing next to us, and saying--
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督来自我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他总是走过来走廊，站在我们旁边，说——
You're standing next to the devil. And you're riding a road to hell.
你正站在恶魔身边。而且你正走在通往地狱的路上。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
I said, "I'll stand here 'til you die. You may as well quit now."
我说，“我会站在这里直到你死掉。你还是现在就退出吧。”
PRI, Public Radio International. international.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。国际。